[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صباح الخير شكرا للانترو دكشن وانا صغيره
كنت عاوزه ابقى حاجات كتيره قوي دكتوره
مدرسه طباخه وفي وقت من الاوقات دكتوره
بطاريه ان كان عندي حب للطبيعه وكان دايما
عندي فضول اعرف الطبيعه بتشتغل ازاي وكنت
بحب البيولوجي
جدا وان انا كنت عايشه في ويلز هي بلد
صغيره جميله جنب جلترا مش
المانيا فهي قدرت ان هي تحافظ على فكره
الطبيعه وان انا اقدر اقعد فعلا وسط
هدوء واشوف الطبيعه واتامل
وافكر لما تميت 16 سنه قررت ان انا انزل
ادرس التصميم في الجامعه الالمانيه وزي اي
حد بيقعد بره مده طويله بيشوف الحاجات
الجميله في بلده بعدين يبتدي يلاحظ حاجات
مختلفه عن الحاجات اللي هو كان متعود
عليها اول حاجه لاحظتها كانت مختلفه شويه
هي كانت اللغه او
الانج والحاجه التانيه برضو ان
فكره الطبيعه الحاجه اللي انا كنت متعو
عليها كانت اصعب الواحد
يوصلها ويلز قدرت ان هي تحافظ على حاجات
كتيره قوي في الطبيعه من غير ما تغير
حاجات غير الحاجات الاساسيه اللي موجوده
احنا في مصر لما بنتطور دايما تلاقي ان
احنا بنتغير ونتحرك من مول لبيت كله
بيعتمد على وصيله مواصلات كلها تقريبا في
بابل احنا على طول قاعدين جوه في ويلز
الواحد ممكن هو ينزل يتمشى ويلاقي نفسه في
وسط طبيعه النهارده مش عايزه اكلمكم قوي
عن اللانج جابس ولا عن ويلز عايزه اكلمكم
عن موضوع اسمه باي مكري لما ناس بتسمع
كلمه باي مكري افتكروا ان هي كلمه
معقده وهي ابسط من كده هي معناها تقليد
الطبيعه والنقل منها في ناس لما بتفكر في
الطبيعه بيفتكروا ان هي حاجه اجريسيف
وفايل نت بنفتكر الكرتونات وعالم الحيوان
والناشونال جيوجرافيك كل ده مدينا احساس
ان الطبيعه دي حاجه متهوره او حاجه صعبه
في جزء اه في الطبيعه الموضوع ده لان ده
جزء من الحياه يعني هتلاقي اه كائن يهجم
على كائن تاني بس عمرك ما تلاقي كائن قرر
انه يدمر بيئه كائن تاني لمجرد ان عاوز
يبني مول مثلا البني ادمين بس هم اللي
بيفكروا بالطريقه دي بايبي مكري فكرتها ان
احنا نشوف ازاي الطبيعه قدرت تحل مشاكل
عندها ونطبق الطريقه دي ونحل مشاكلنا احنا
كمان الطبيعه فيها باترن واستراتيجيات
موجوده بتستعملها في كل حاجه فلو احنا
درسنا المواضيع دي واستعملنا ان احنا نطبق
حلول لمشاكل ونعمل بيها تصميمات ممكن
نلاقي ان الموضوع هيبقى
افضل عاوزه اديكم فكره انا عرفت عن باي
مكري ازاي هي كانت خلال كذا موقف حصلوا
خلال سنين كتيره وكان عندي دايما نفس
الاقتناع ان احنا كبني ادمين نبقى فاصلين
نفسنا تماما عن الطبيعه ده مش في صالحنا
موضوع البابل اللي قلت لكم عليه ده مش صح
احنا جزء من الطبيعه ولازم نبقى فاهمين
الموضوع ده كويس جدا لما كان بيبقى مطلوب
مني في الكليه ان انا اعمل تصميم كنت
دايما ببص على الشيبس اللي هي الاورجانك
المدي شيبس اللي موجوده في الطبيعه وابتدي
اعمل تصميم
بيه في حاجه تانيه برض لازم نفكر فيها ان
الطبيعه بتقدر تتاقلم بطريقه سهله جدا
واسهل بكتير من الطريقه اللي البني ادمين
بيعملوها دلوقتي التطوير بتاع الطبيعه ذكي
جدا يعني مثلا لو ورقه الشمس في الشجره
اتقطعت الورقه اللي تحتها اللي هي ورقه
الضل بتتحول لورقه الشمس التاقلم ده ما
اعتقدش ان البني ادمين لسه وصلوا للمرحله
دي فان احنا نتعلم منها دي حاجه في
صالحنا وانا في تانيه جامعه كان مطلوب ان
انا اعمل بحث عن موضوع او كذا حاجه من
ليسته زمايلي
اختاروا ضيع اللي هي كاتشي او ملفته
للانتباه زي الو هاوس موفمنت وملزم كل
الحاجات دي حاجات في التصميم انا اخترت ان
انا ادرس عن مصمم مشهور اعرف المصممين
بيشتغلوا ازاي بيفكروا ازاي فاخترت مصمم
ما كنتش اعرف عنه اي حاجه اسمه روس لاف
جروف خلال البحث ده عرفت كذا حاجه اولا
عرفت ان هو من ويلز برضو فتقريبا هو نفس
الدماغ يعني وبساط الحاجه الثانيه عرفتها
ان هو بيعمل حاجه اسمها الحاجه الثانيه
هو بيعمل طريقه تصميم اسمها الفات فري
ديزاين برض جمله فات فري ديزاين ده غريب
جدا ومن مصمم اغرب هو معترف ان هو مصمم
غريب فات فري ديزاين هو للا ان هي موجوده
في الطبيعه يعني
الطبيعه دايما تبقى بتشيل الحاجات
الاضافيه ما بتزود مواد لمجرد ان هي بنحط
خشب على تنجيد ت هي الحاجات البيسك
الاستراكشر هي اللي موجوده هنلاقيها في
العضم هنلاقيها في الليفا هنلاقيها في ورق
الشجر كل ده بيبقى الحاجات
الاساسيه هو فكر ان هو يعمل فات فري
ديزاين ان هو يفكر بنفس الطريقه دي زي
الطبيعه ويعمل بيها تصميم فده من اشهر
التصميمات بتاعته اسمها او اسمه الجو تشير
ا هي نفس الفكره ان هو شال الحاجات
الزياده اللي مش محتاجينها وسايب الحاجات
البيسك بالطريقه دي التصميم خفيف مريح
بيشتغل وفي نفس الوقت مش بيهدر مواد هو مش
محتاجها بعد الموضوع ده بكذا سنه وانا
بحضر شهاده
الماجستير سمعت تد توك لواحده اسمها دينا
باو مايستر دينا باو مايستر هي من مؤسسين
باي م مكري هي واحده تانيه اسمها جانين
بانيس الوك بتاعها كان هايل وهي كانت
بتقول ان البني ادمين صغيرين جدا في السن
صغيرين يعني احنا لو عملنا سكيلينج للار
بليون سنه بتوع الارض عملنا لهم سكيلينج
ان هم يبقوا سنه واحده بس هنلاقي ان
الطبيعه موجوده طول السنه طورت وتعلمت
وعملت ادابت البني ادمين ظهروا في اخر شهر
خالص فزي لما بيبقى الواحد عنده مشكله
بيسال الشخص الاكبر انا محتاج نصيحه محتاج
ان انا اعرف احل المشكله دي بطريقه هي دي
نفس فكره باي مي مكري نعتبر ان الطبيعه دي
الحاجه اللي عندها خبره ونبتدي نتعلم منها
عشان نحل مشاكل ممكن ما تكونش لسه ظهرت
ظهرت للطبيعه عرفت تحلها فهي دي نفس
الفكره بما اني اكلمت عن جنين بانيس
فخلينا برض نتكلم عنها لان
دي من اول الناس اللي تتكلم عن باي مكري
وتكتب كتاب عنه في
1990 هي بتدي توكس كلهم حلوين قوي من ضمن
التوكس بتوعها هي اكلمت
عن نماذج موجوده في
باكري من اشهر التطبيقات لبا مكري هي
البرين البرين ده قطر مشهور في اليابان
واول ما اتعمل كان شكله عامل زي الطلقه
البولت
لما كان بيعدي من تحت نفق كان بيعمل صوت
برضو زي البولت وده بسبب حاجه اسمها
السونيك بوم المهندس اللي كان شغال في
المشروع ده طلب منه ان هو يحل المشكله دي
لان الناس كانت بتشتكي من الصوت جدا وهو
المهندس كان من الناس اللي بتحب تتفرج على
اليور هو اسمه بيرد واتشر بيسافر يتفرج
على اليور يدرسهم فلقى ان في طائر اسمه
الكينج فيشر ولقى ان الكينج فيشر ده بيعدي
من الهوا للميه من غير ما يعمل اي صوت
خالص ولا دوشه ولا طرطشه عشان يقدر يصطاد
السمك خد الشكل ده وطبقه للبول ترين
بالطريقه دي هو حل مشكله الصوت في نفس
الوقت القطر بقى بيمشي بطريقه اسرع وبقى
بيمشي بطريقه ايفيشنت
اكتر خلينا نفصل كده في نص القصه عشان بس
ما تناموش مني ونتكلم جد شويه ممكن يكون
جه في بالكم سؤال لازم ابقى مصمم عشان
اعمل باي مكري والاجابه لا ممكن تكونوا
انتم بتعملوا تصميم او حل المشكله من غير
ما تاخدوا بالكم ممكن اديكم برض مثال لناس
عملوا باي مكري من غير ما ياخدوا بالهم
وده الايفنت اللي هايل بتاع النهارده
انتروبي وكوس يري موجودين في كل حته في
الطبيعه مثلا هجره الطيور هجره الطيور
الناس بتشوف ان هي حاجه كيوتك حاجه دوشه
حاجه ش نظام وده مش حقيقي هو بيبقى في
نظام ان الطيور عارفه هي رايحه من بوينت
اي ل بوينت بي وعارفه كمان ان هم ما يخبطو
في بعض لو خدنا بقى النظام ده وفكرنا ان
احنا نعمل حل لمشكله المرور اللي عندنا في
مصر اكيد احنا متفقين ان احنا محتاجين
يعني حل المشكله دي ليه ما نفكر للحل اللي
خلاص اتعمل في الطبيعه ان انا اعمل باي
ميمك انا محتاجه مجموعه مجموعه من الناس
من فيلز مختلفه عشان يفيدوني بمعلومات
مختلفه اول حد هبقى محتاجه محتاجاه عشان
المجموعه بتاعتي هو الجست ان انا بتكلم ان
انا بتعلم من الطبيعه فالبوست اول حد
هيعلم مني او هيفيدني في معلومات عن
الطبيعه بعد كده دور بقى لحد مثلا من
الفيزكس او كيمستري او مات حسب المشكله
اللي انا عاوزه احلها وعموما لما يبقى
عندكم مشكله او تصميم عاوزين تعملوه كل ما
يبقى عندكم معلومات اكتر كل ما يبقى احسن
اوكي في بقى كذا موضوع طالعين بيبتدوا
بالبايو زي بايونكس بايو انجينيرينج
بيوفيليا وحاجات كتيره قوي هم كلهم شبه
بايوم ممكي في ان هم بيحاولوا يتعلموا
فعلا من الطبيعه البيوميمكري مميزه في ان
هي
بتتعلم حل المشاكل ازاي من الطبيعه
وبتتعلم من الطبيعه كستم والسيستم دي او
الاستراتيجيات دي احنا نقدر نطبقها في
حلول مشاكل لينا احنا كمان زي ما قلنا
عشان ابتدي اعمل باي مكري في
طريقتين وال طريقتين دول اسمهم الباي مكري
ديزاين سيرال اوكي و معلش الموضوع ابتد
يبقى ممل شويه بس لازم اديكم فكره ف في
طريقتين اول حاجه ان انا يبقى عندي
بيولوجي وبعدين اعمل بيهم تصميم او ان
يبقى عندي مشكله بدور على حاجه في الطبيعه
حلت المشكله دي فعلا وابتدي ادرسها واعمل
تصميم شبهه عاده تاني طريقه هي اكتر طريقه
الناس بتستعملها فخلينا نركز فيها اكترر
اولا لازم اعرف ايه هي المشكله ولازم اعرف
مين اللي هيست الحل بتاعي هل الحل هيبقى
منتج او نظام ابتدي افكر فيه بعد كده
ابتدي اشوف نموذج موجود في
الطبيعه عشان اعمل كده
لازم يبقى عندي سؤال يعني مثلا لو انا
عاوزه اعمل تصميم لمبنى بيتهو في الصيف
فممكن اسال سؤال بيولوجي هو ازاي الطبيعه
قدرت ان هي تتحكم في درجه الحراره
بتاعتها بطريقه طبيعيه لما يبقى عندي
السؤال ده محتاجه اجابه ليه عشان اشوف
انسبريشن موجوده في الطبيعه اسهل طريقه
تعملوا كده ان انتم تدخلوا على موقع اسمه
ask
الموقع ده حتى لو انتم مش بتفكروا تعملوا
باي مكري فمجرد ان انتم يبقى عندكم فضول
وتدخلوا وتعرفوا عن حاجات موجوده في
الطبيعه دي لوحدها حاجه كويسه
فابتدع الموقع وشوفوا اتعلموا حاجات جديده
لما الاقي بقى خلاص الانسبريشن اللي انا
عاوزاها من الطبيعه ابتدي احل المشكله
بتاعتي بنفس الطريقه واعمل تصميم او فكره
بعد ما اخلص ده ببتدي اعمل مقارنه تصميم
قدام قواعد الحياه لايف برنسبل دول ست
برنسبل
موجودين في كل حاجه في الطبيعه احنا لو
قدرنا نعمل تصميم بيستعمل اثنين لاه طبعا
الاوبتيما ان هو يستعمل السته لو قدرنا
نعمل التصميم بيمشي على البرنب دي هيبقى
طبعا التصميم مستمر اكتر
واحسن وممكن الاقي برضو حاجات في التصميم
ان هو تتحسن تتعدى خلينا بقى نرجع للقصه
اللي انا كنت بحكيها لكم في الاول
دي لما عرفت عن باي مكري ابتديت اطارد
الموقع بتاع الي مكري انستيتيوت كنت بدخل
تقريبا كل يوم اعرف ايه اللي بيحصل وايه
الابديت واكتشفت ان في ديزاين كومبتيشن
بتحصل كل سنتين كل سنه بيبقى في موضوع
بيبقوا طالبين ان احنا نلاقي حل للمشكله
دي او للموضوع ده السنه دي كانت المشكله
هي حل لنظام في الميه فكلمت مع كذا حد من
زمايلي عملنا
مجموعه وابتدينا نشتغل على النظام ده
وانا بشتغل في التصميم اكتر قعدت افكر
يمكن لو عملنا كويس نقابل دينا باو مايستر
ودجانيني وكل الناس اللي علموني باي مكري
اللي ظريف ان احنا فعلا عملنا كويس سافرنا
بوستن عملنا بشين قدام دينا باو مايستر
ودجانيني وفزنا الكوميشن
دي احنا كنا طالعين من ضمن ست فرق امريكا
وكندا مكسيكو سويدن بلجيم
ومصر وكنا طالعين كان في جائزتين ههم
كانوا في بيبلز شويس وكان في الجايزه
الكبيره احنا كده كده كنا حاسين ان احنا
كسبانين مجرد ان احنا يعني سافرنا وقلنا
الفكره دي بس قلنا يمكن ناخ بيبل تويس لان
بيبلز تويس معتمد على البيتش فقلنا احنا
نروح نبتش كويس نوزع ستيكرز وبوك ماركس
ونعمل شو حلو ويمكن يكسبونا يعني لما ده
ما حصلش قلنا كويس الحمد لله وبعدين كنا
مستنيين بقى يقولوا الجراند برايز مين
كسبها لقينا الحكام يعني مبتسمين ومركزين
قوي معانا وهم بيقولوا الانون سمنت بعدين
سمعنا اسم فريق مش موجود اصلا من ضمن
السته اسمه
ايجي قلنا ايجي يعني ايه الاسم ايه ده ف
لقيناهم بيقولوا لنا يلا افضلوا وقولوا
انونس مننت ومبروك وانتم كسبتوا ففهمنا ان
الانجوي جاب اللي قلتلكم عليها في الاول
خالص دي لعبه دورها هم قصدهم اي جي اوزمو
اللي هو الفريق بتاعنا فاحنا الحمد لله
كسبنا ق قلتلكم قبل كده ان احنا كنا حاسين
ان احنا كده كده كسبانين ده بسبب ان احنا
كنا حاسين ان احنا عاملين تصميم فعلا حل
مشكله احنا كنا شايفينها في مصر دي مشكله
نظام الرا اللي موجود في
الفيوم لقينا ان الفلاح عشان ينقل الميه
من
الترعه
للمزرعه بيحتاج طرمبه طرمبه دي بيبقى
بياجرها تقريبا بالاسبوع مش هينفع ياجرها
باليوم ا فبين قل كميه ميه كبيره وبيحط في
مجر قدام المزارع ولما بيحتاج يسقي
بيستعمل الميه دي الميه لما تتساب لمده
اسبوع بتبقى يعني بتبتدي تجمع بكتيريا
وبتعفى فده مش احسن حاجه طبعا فاحنا بصينا
لحاجتين في الطبيعه عشان نحل المشكله دي
النظام الدموي بتاع الزرافه والنظام
الهضمي بتاع الجمل الجمل ده بالذات من
الانسبريشن اللي موجوده في البايوم
بتاعنا البايوم يعني البيئه اللي احنا
عايشين فيها ودي من القواعد اللي قلت لكم
عليها في الطبيعه لان كل حاجه في في
الطبيعه بتستعمل الحاجات اللي حواليها
عمرك ما تلاقي طائر مثلا سافر لغايه تركيا
عشان يجيب احدث انواع خشب عشان يحطها في
العشه بتاعته يبقى عنده عش يعني احلى من
بقيه الطيور البني ادمين بس هم اللي
بيفكروا بالطريقه دي لو احنا ابتدينا نفكر
بالطريقه اللي الطبيعه بتفكر بيه يمكن مش
هنحس بالازمه اللي احنا ابتدينا نحس بيه
والحاجات المستورده والاسعار اللي ابتدت
تغلى
محتاجين نفهم ان كل حاجه حوالينا بتشتغل
وبتفكر بنفس الطريقه حتى اجسامنا بيشتغلوا
بنفس الطريقه فليه كمان منتجاتنا
بيوتنا شغلنا وطريقه شغلنا كمان ممكن نعمل
نظام يشتغل احسن
بكتير فاكرين في الاول خالص لما قلت لكم
على موضوع الانجوي جابس حد فيكم مثلا حاول
يعرف ازاي الكائنات بتكلم بعض من غير ما
يبقوا بيتكلموا نفس
اللغه فيله مثلا بيدبدب رجليهم او بيخبطوا
جامد قوي عشان يعملوا فيبريشن على الارض
الطريقه دي بتخلي الكائنات التانيه تعرف
ان في خطر او في مشكله طريقه بسيطه جدا
احنا ممكن برضو نبتدي نفهم ونتعلم الحاجات
دي ونستعملها في حلول لمشاكل لينا احنا
كمان باي مكري مش معناه ان انا ارجع لورا
او استعمل حاجات بدائيه بس لازم نفهم ان
التطوير بتاع البني ادم ماشي بس في طريقه
التكنولوجي الطبيعه بتطور بس بطريقه
مستمره اكتر فاحنا لو ابتدينا نفهم هي
بتطور ازاي بطريقه معقده وبسيطه في نفس
الوقت بطريقه جميله بطريقه بسيطه وطبقنا
في التصميمات وحلول بتاعتنا احنا ممكن
نلاقي ان في حاجات افضل هتبتدي
تحصلك ونبص حوالينا ونطلع بره السمارت فون
ونبتدي نشوف ادعوكم ان انتم كلكم تعملوا
كده ويمكن تعملوا تصميم باي ممك قريب
[تصفيق]
شكرا